Trascrizione: Alessio Politi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Chi di voi, nella vita,
ha avuto almeno una volta la febbre alta?
Alzi la mano.
Si sarà quindi ritrovato
in questa condizione:
a letto, con i brividi, dolori articolari
e magari anche con un forte mal di gola.
Sono sicura che la maggior parte
di noi, e di voi, in questa situazione
si sarà rivolta al proprio medico
per capire quale fosse
il proprio stato di salute in quel momento
e come ripristinarlo
nel minor tempo possibile.
Perché?
La prima domanda che io faccio:
perché io, in una situazione del genere,
devo rivolgermi al [mio] medico
e non pensare di dover, semplicemente,
ascoltare il mio corpo
e dargli la possibilità di fermarsi,
mettersi sotto le coperte
e prendersi un buon brodo di pollo
e aspettare, aspettare che passi
e uscire quindi più forti di prima
da una sfida che il nostro corpo,
appunto, ha avuto.
Passa continuamente il messaggio
che dobbiamo essere
sempre perfetti, sempre al top,
che non ci possiamo ammalare.
Ultimamente, c'è una pubblicità
che passa continuamente,
dove c'è una ragazza che corre.
Si ferma perché ha un forte mal di gola,
e c'è qualcuno che le dice:
no, non ti devi fermare.
C'è una pasticca.
C'è una pasticca per tutto.
E anzi, invece di darti
la confezione da 20
ti faccio la confezione da 40,
perché così almeno ce l'hai sempre con te
e sai che cosa prendere.
Sono anche sicura
che, in questa situazione,
la maggior parte di noi e di voi
ha preso un farmaco,
un farmaco che gli è stato consigliato
dalla nonna, dalla mamma -
la famosa tachipirina -
semplicemente per abbassare la febbre,
perché bisogna subito ripartire.
E senza fare alcun test,
spesso, purtroppo,
gli sono stati somministrati, magari,
anche degli antibiotici;
sempre perché, magari,
un pochino di mal di gola -
cavolo ma ha detto il fruttivendolo,
me l'ha detto la zia
che basta che prenda un Augmentin
e tutto andrà bene.
Quindi la seconda domanda che io faccio è:
perché devo prendere un farmaco
senza nemmeno sapere
se è quello giusto da prendere?
Ed è questo uso inappropriato dei farmaci
che ci ha portato oggi
in una condizione drammatica,
perché tantissimi batteri,
responsabili appunto di queste malattie -
che per carità, non sono gravi,
spesso si possono autorisolvere -
sono diventati resistenti
agli antibiotici.
Siamo tornati come nel Medioevo:
nel Medioevo si moriva
per le malattie infettive
perché gli antibiotici non li avevamo,
non li conoscevamo.
Oggi ce li abbiamo, tanti, fortunatamente;
ma il loro utilizzo indiscriminato
ha portato a far sì
che questi batteri
abbiano cominciato a difendersi
e che siano quindi diventati resistenti.
E quindi noi non abbiamo più armi
contro molti di loro.
Non so se avete sentito parlare
del "New Delhi".
Il New Delhi è un batterio
che si è sviluppato
non tanto lontano da noi,
nelle province di Massa-Carrara,
che è diventato resistente
a tutti gli antibiotici disponibili.
È una Klebsiella Pneumoniae,
una specie di batterio
che generalmente dà una semplice cistite,
può dare comunque delle banali infezioni;
ma se è divenuto resistente
a tutti gli antibiotici,
non abbiamo armi contro di lui
e ci può uccidere.
Quindi è probabilmente arrivato
il momento di fermarci
e di capire che i nostri comportamenti
hanno poi delle conseguenze,
e delle conseguenze anche molto gravi.
La terza domanda che io vi pongo
è quella di fare un esperimento,
di guardare la persona
che è accanto a voi:
ha i vostri stessi occhi?
I vostri stessi capelli?
No, è diversa da voi.
Questo perché noi siamo appunto unici.
Siamo tutti diversi.
Perché allora io devo prendere
lo stesso dosaggio, magari,
della tachipirina,
che magari in quel momento mi servo
dell'antibiotico uguale al mio vicino?
Quello che è stato fatto fino ad oggi
in questo gruppo di persone,
è quello che potete vedere qua:
di fronte alla stessa malattia,
dare a tutti lo stesso tipo
di trattamento.
E soltanto il piccolo gruppo in verde
non ha avuto effetti collaterali,
e il farmaco ha funzionato.
Cioè era il farmaco
adatto in quel momento,
e adatto a loro.
Quindi quello che dovrebbe
essere fatto, invece,
non è quello di trattare tutti
nello stesso modo,
ma di capire qual è
il farmaco adatto a me.
Il dosaggio, adatto a me.
Una volta non era possibile
fare questo, non lo sapevamo.
Avevamo trovato la malattia,
il principio attivo:
ok, trattamento standardizzato.
Oggi questo è possibile.
È possibile perché noi abbiamo
un libretto delle istruzioni,
che è il nostro DNA.
Il DNA è una molecola che è formata
da una doppia elica arrotolata,
formata da una sequenza
di quattro basi azotate,
che si chiamano nucleotidi -
adenina, timina, citosina, guanina -
e si trova all'interno
del nucleo delle nostre cellule.
Fate conto che, se srotolato,
ha la lunghezza di due metri
e lì dentro c'è scritto tutto su di noi.
Ed è unico per ognuno di noi:
è la nostra impronta digitale.
Dobbiamo semplicemente andarla a leggere.
Madonna, sarà sicuramente
un esame costosissimo,
un prelievo dolorosissimo
e difficilissimo,
che io assolutamente non posso fare.
Per andare a prelevare il DNA vostro,
basta semplicemente un tampone boccale:
è un tampone molto simile a un cottonfioc,
che viene passato all'interno
della mucosa boccale,
si prelevano le cellule di sfaldamento,
si trattano con determinati reattivi
e si può estrarre, a questo punto, il DNA.
La tecnica migliore
che abbiamo oggi a disposizione,
per l'analisi del DNA -
e quindi per riuscire ad andare a leggere,
appunto, tutta quella sequenza -
è il Next Generation Sequencing,
Cioè il sequenziamento
di nuova generazione.
Una volta questo tipo di tecnica,
all'inizio, ai suoi esordi comunque,
era disponibile soltanto
in pochi centri specializzati,
che non erano accessibili a tutti.
Oggi, invece, è possibile
fare questa analisi:
occorrono sicuramente ancora
dei centri specializzati,
e del personale che sia addestrato;
ma è fruibile da tutti noi,
è un esame abbordabilissimo.
Fate conto che, quando è nato,
per fare il sequenziamento
di un intero genoma
occorrevano giorni,
e si dovevano spendere migliaia di euro.
Oggi è possibile fare questo esame
in circa tre, quattro ore,
al costo di cento euro.
Quindi con cento euro
voi potete andare a leggere
i capitoli del vostro libro di istruzioni
che sono coinvolti
nel metabolismo dei farmaci.
Perché quando noi troviamo
un nuovo farmaco,
troviamo il principio attivo,
e di conseguenza sappiamo, anche,
quale è l'enzima che lo metabolizza.
Ad esempio alcuni di noi
hanno una mutazione in alcuni enzimi
che non ci permettono proprio
di metabolizzare quel farmaco,
che quindi non è adatto a noi
perché semplicemente è inefficace.
In altri casi, invece,
ci può creare degli effetti collaterali.
In altri casi ancora,
ne serve semplicemente
un dosaggio maggiore o minore,
quindi non è soltanto il principio
ma magari è il dosaggio
che deve essere aggiustato.
Ma se noi non andiamo a leggere
il libretto delle istruzioni,
non lo sapremo mai.
Quindi, per minimizzare
gli effetti collaterali dei farmaci,
e quindi far sì che siano i nostri amici,
quando questi appunto siano necessari,
dobbiamo andare a leggere il nostro DNA.
Quello al quale io sto lavorando però,
è quello di riunire tutte le informazioni
scritte nel nostro libretto di istruzioni
in un semplice codice a barre.
Un codice a barre che deve, e può essere,
continuamente aggiornabile,
dove c'è praticamente scritto tutto,
tutto quello che ci serve
per mantenere e migliorare
il nostro stato di salute.
Ad esempio, la nostra capacità
di metabolizzare alcuni farmaci.
Vi faccio un esempio.
Qualche tempo fa è venuta da me
una signora a fare un prelievo,
che era in gravidanza.
E mi dice: dottoressa, senta,
ma a me il ginecologo,
per telefono, mi ha detto:
guarda, hai la febbre,
prenditi il paracetamolo.
La famosa tachipirina.
La tachipirina, infatti,
è uno dei farmaci di elezione
contro la febbre alta
e che è uno dei pochi
che è consentito in gravidanza
per la maggior parte
delle donne in gravidanza:
ma probabilmente non per tutte.
Perché questa signora mi ha detto:
mi ha detto di prendere
il paracetamolo, la tachipirina
che però io non mi ricordo,
la mia mamma non si ricorda,
se quando ero piccola,
e ho preso questo farmaco,
io ho avuto degli effetti collaterali.
Come posso fare per saperlo?
"Next Generation sequencìng".
Quindi andare a leggere quel gene
che è coinvolto nel metabolismo
del paracetamolo
e capire se è adatto a lei.
Se lei avesse fatto l'analisi del DNA,
e quindi la cosiddetta farmacogenomica,
lo saprebbe.
E addirittura se lo ricorderebbe,
o non avrebbe avuto
bisogno di ricordarselo,
se questa informazione
fosse stata inserita nel codice a barre.
Quindi qualsiasi medico
avrebbe avuto la possibilità
di andare lì con una semplice
pistola a infrarossi
e andare a scaricare tutti i farmaci
che era possibile utilizzare
per quella persona.
Tra quelli che avrebbe dovuto prescrivere,
ad esempio, in quel momento.
Tutto, appunto, in un codice a barre.
Ma io direi ancora di più.
Non soltanto per quanto riguarda
la farmacogenomica,
ma tutti gli aspetti che ci riguardano
e sono scritti nel nostro
libretto di istruzioni.
Perché se io vi dicessi, ad esempio,
che se si è intolleranti al lattosio
potremmo essere depressi?
Cosa c'entra l'intolleranza al lattosio?
Sono depressa perché non posso
mangiare niente,
guardo tutti che mi mangiano davanti
e quindi sono depresso, ok?
No. C'è una correlazione.
Perché sempre nel mio
libretto delle istruzioni,
nel capitolo che riguarda
la digestione del lattosio
e quindi, in particolar modo,
nel gene che codifica per l'enzima
che serve per digerire il lattosio,
che si chiama lattasi,
io basta che lo legga,
che io vada a vedere se funziona,
tramite il Next Generation
Sequencing, per esempio;
possono essere utilizzate
anche tecniche un po' meno sensibili
che sono ancora meno costose
rispetto al Next Generation Sequencing,
che vi dicono: guarda, ok,
tu hai una mutazione in quel gene,
non puoi digerire il lattosio.
E questo cosa c'entra con la depressione?
Perché se io non digeriscono il lattosio,
il lattosio arriva
nel mio intestino indigerito.
Nel mio intestino,
ci sono una serie di batteri
che possono essere
nostri amici o nostri nemici.
O meglio: se noi diamo loro
da mangiare le cose giuste,
diamo loro un ambiente
ottimale in cui vivere,
loro ci aiutano nel mantenere
il nostro stato di salute.
Se noi li nutriamo in modo scorretto -
in questo caso dando loro,
ad esempio, del lattosio indigerito,
viene utilizzato da batteri
che sono nostri nemici
e che producono una serie di molecole
che hanno un effetto negativo,
tra cui inibire, per esempio,
la produzione di serotonina.
La serotonina è l'ormone del buonumore,
ed è anche l'ormone sul quale agiscono
tutti i farmaci antidepressivi.
Intolleranza al lattosio,
quindi depressione:
possono essere correlati.
Non pensate che, magari,
uno psicologo avrebbe tratto vantaggio
nel sapere se siete
intolleranti al lattosio?
E se riuscisse ad avere
una visione più olistica
della vostra unicità?
E sapete anche un'altra cosa?
Quale eccipiente si trova
in quasi tutti i farmaci?
È il lattosio.
Quindi magari, ok, quel principio attivo
io lo riesco a metabolizzare,
quel dosaggio è giusto:
ma cavolo, io sono
intollerante al lattosio,
quindi a me comunque
quel tipo di farmaco mi fa male.
Occorre che ne trovi uno
dove come eccipiente non c'è lattosio.
Quindi all'interno di quel codice a barre
ci dovrebbero essere scritte
tutta una serie di informazioni
che possono, chiaramente
con il vostro consenso, essere utilizzate
per mantenere il vostro stato di salute.
Perché spesso facciamo
le analisi, si, è vero:
ma ogni volta ce le dimentichiamo,
dobbiamo portarci dietro il cartaceo:
andiamo una volta dal gastroenterologo,
una volta dallo psicologo,
una volta dal neurologo.
E magari anche il medico, in quel momento,
non ha la capacità di individuare un esame
il cui esito, in realtà,
potrebbe avere un risvolto
sulla terapia che può darvi.
Vi ripeto, uno di farmacogenetica.
E magari l'intolleranza al lattosio
è stata prescritta dal gastroenterologo:
però è utile anche per lo psicologo,
è utile anche per il dermatologo,
perché sempre l'intolleranza al lattosio
può essere associata alla dermatite.
Venite curati per una certa causa
quando in realtà, semplicemente,
basta togliere il lattosio
dall'alimentazione.
Quindi, secondo quello
che la scienza ci dice,
se vogliamo migliorare
il nostro stato di salute, mantenerlo,
dobbiamo per forza andare a leggere
il nostro libretto delle istruzioni.
Oggi che è possibile,
dobbiamo avere accesso
e poter utilizzare queste tecniche,
senza se e senza ma.
Grazie.
(Applausi)